bonjour à tous La séance est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au
Gouvernement la première question va
être posée par Monsieur Charles Fournier
pour le groupe
écologiste madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les les ministres ma mes chers
collègues ma ma question s'adresse au
ministre du Logement hier à l'occasion
de la Journée international des droits
de l'enfant le gouvernement a présenté
son plan de lutte contre les violences
faites aux enfants et c'est nécessaire
mais parmi ces violences insupportables
il y en a une qui se joue tous les jours
devant nous et dans nos villes c'est
celle que subissent les enfants
lorsqu'ils dorment dans la rue il
s'appelle Zac michaelll Hermès Élisa il
dorment dans les rues de la ville de
tour dans ma ville comme les quelques
3000 enfants dans notre pays qui ne
bénéficient pas de la protection que
nous leur devons c'est insupportable
depuis 12 jours j'accueille quelques
familles dans ma permanence transformée
temporairement en centre d'hébergement
d'urgence ce n'est pas plus une solution
que de dormir dans une école mais c'est
pour lancer un éè cri d'alerte dès ce
soir ce sont de nombreux enfants et leur
familles qui appelleront à nouveau le
115 pour espérer que la rotation leur
soit favorable beaucoup encore seront
sans solution et c'est insupportable
l'abé pierre disait les hommes
politiques ne connaissent la misère que
par les statistiques on ne pleure pas
devant les chiffres s'il savaiit à quel
point cette phrase raisonne fort
aujourd'hui alors où je vous parle vous
savez monsieur le ministre que 2800
enfants dormiront dehors ce soir à
l'heure où je vous parle vous savez
qu'il manque au moins 10000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence que le logement
d'abord n'est ni une réponse pour tout
le monde ni une solution pleinement
active à l'heure où je vous parle
monsieur le ministre je n'ai aucune
réponse à mes courriers et
sollicitations ne me répondez pas par
des chiffres ne me dites pas que vous
faites tant et tant et que le budget va
augmenter en vrai il va baisser par
rapport aux dépenses 2023 je vous le dis
monsieur le ministre derrière les
chiffres ce sont des enfants en danger
des familles alors ma question êtes-vous
prêt à venir sur le terrain pour
regarder la situation êtes-vous prêt à
réouvrir les discussions sur les 10000
places d'urgence ne me répondez pas par
des chiffres dites-moi où dormiront les
enfants ce soir à
tour je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Aurore berger ministre des
Solidarités et des
familles merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Fournier selon la
face et selon l'Unicef il y a
2822 enfants qui dorment à la rue c'est
donc 2822 enfants de trop qui dorment à
la rue et donc il y a ce que nous avons
fait et il y a ce que nous devons faire
ce que nous avons fait c'est préserver
l'hébergement d'urgence et vous le savez
c'est 203000 places aujourd'hui
d'hébergement d'urgence qui ont été
consacré et c'est une augmentation
considérable de moyens et vous le savez
là aussi c'est 40 % de moyens
supplémentaires depuis 2017 il y a
évidemment ce que nous devons continuer
à faire parce qu'en vérité aucun parent
aucun enfant ne souhaite être dans un
hébergement d'urgence ça doit être une
solution temporaire c'est là-dessus que
la première ministre agi c'est là-dessus
que Charlotte cobel agi c'est là-dessus
que Patrice vergrit agi de manière à ce
qu'encore une fois ce ne soit qu'une
solution temporaire de mise à l'abri
pour garantir surtout qu'ils aient accès
à un logement pérenne avec notamment
logement d'abord c'est ça notre
véritable enjeu et puis pour ceux qui
malgré tout doivent être dans
l'hébergement d'urgence doivent avoir
cette mise à l'abri c'est un enjeu
majeur qui est l'accès à la
scolarisation de ses enfants c'est ce
que nous faisons avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale notamment parce
qu'un enfant qui est dans le mallogement
parce que l'hébergement d'urgence ça
n'est pas du logement péren doit avoir
accès à une scolarité normale c'est ce
que nous faisons parce qu'aujourd'hui ça
n'était pas forcément le cas c'est la
question des médiateurs scolaires c'est
la question des médiateurs sociaux pour
garantir qu'encore une fois la mise à
l'abri ce ne soit pas de la précarité
supplémentaire pour nos enfants ce soit
une mise à l'abri sur l'ensemble des
aspects de leur vie sociale et familiale
c'est ça que nous faisons et c'est comme
ça que nous arrivons à répondre à cette
urgence évidemment je vous remercie
monsieur le député
madame la ministre merci de votre
réponse ce soir encore des enfants
dormiront dehors et vous ne me répondez
pas cette situation est insupportable
elle continue elle devrai toutes et tous
nous
émouvoir je vous remercie madame la
ministre monsieur le député je pense
qu'il y a pas un membre du gouvernement
ou un député qui n'est pas saisi
d'émotion par cette question le sujet
c'est pas la surenchè de l'émotion le
seul sujet qui nous importe à tous c'est
de garantir une solution durable à
l'ensemble de ces enfants à l'ensemble
de ces famille et c'est comme cela que
nous devons travailler ensemble je suis
prête à venir chez vous comme je suis
prête à aller dans n'importe quel
territoire pour aller voir ses enfants
et aller voir ses familles je vous
remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame un peu
de silence s'il vous plaît la parole est
à Madame violette SPB pour le groupe
Renaissance merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre Yannick
Maé Saint-Brévin Lespin Vincent jambbrin
la les roses Anne Françoise piedalu
plourescamp ce sont nos maires nos élus
les symboles de notre République tous
victime de violence et d'attaque indigne
parce que les maires parce que les élus
sont dévoués au service de leurs
concitoyens et de l'intérêt général nos
maires sont réunis cette semaine à Paris
pour le 105e congrès des maires sur le
thème commune attaquée République
menacée dans nos circonscriptions ils
nous font remonter régulièrement un
sentiment d'empêchement et d'impuissance
des élus ils craignent la violence sur
leur mairie leur permanence leur
domicile et même envers leurs familles
ils dénoncent la haine en ligne et les
menaces et alert sur ce qu'ils appellent
la fatigue républicaine je tiens à leur
dire que les parlementaires sont à leur
côté nous travaillons au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale sur leur
protection comme sur le statut pour
aboutir à des avancées concrètes au
premier semestre 2024 et notamment suite
au au travail que je mène avec mon
collègue Sébastien Jumel saluons ici
l'abnégation des maires qui mérite le
respect de tous le gouvernement aussi
agit avec la mise en place des référents
élus en préfecture la création d'une
ligne de suivi psychologique le travail
en cours sur les indemnités et la veille
renforcée sur les atteintes aux élus oui
notre majorité est au travail pour les
protéger pour que
demain aucun citoyen ne craigne de
s'engager dans un mandat d'élu local
pour que demain aucun maire ne soit
menacé ou attaqué pour que demain aucune
famille ne soit victime monsieur le
ministre comment comptez-vous préserver
l'engagement républicain de nos mares et
de nos élus locaux je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
géraldin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres
Maes mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la présidente madame la
députée VI permettez-moi effet où les
maires de France se réunissent en
congrès de leur apporter comme j'imagine
toute la représentation nationale le
soutien dans une société qui est de plus
en plus violente et vous
avez et vous avez
raison certains ici ont été ma c'est pas
le cas de tout le monde en effet je peux
le dire monsieur député min je veux dire
que Monsieur le Député jumelle et
vousmême monsieur député jum n même
apporte sans doute dans la mission que
vous allez rendre au gouvernement des
réponses à la violence qui touche les Mr
donc je voudrais dire que SEP menances
sur 10 sont le fait d'élus avec des
administrés et forth heureusement
essentiellement des outrages
essentiellement des insultes très peu de
violence physique mais lorsqu'elles
arrivent elles sont évidemment
extrêmement difficiles et on l'a vu bien
évidemment extrêmement grave 3500 MRES
sont désormais dans le dispositif alarme
élu les 36000 maires devraient y être
avec les services de monsieur le garde
des saau nous avons avec monsieur le
garde des saau apporté notre
contribution au travail qu'a fait
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat pour
que ce soit les mêmes sanctions pour les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique et
les élus de la République le texte sera
publié complètement au début de l'année
2024 pour que les tribunaux puissent
condamner fermement les attaques contre
les élus et nous devons continuer à
former les policiers les gendarmes plus
de 5000 aujourd'hui c'est le cas des
procureurs de la République qui je sais
rencontre partout arrondissement par
arrondissement les procureurs de la
République les sous-préfets les préfets
les élus ce qui touche madame la députée
les maires c'est la crise de l'autorité
au sein de notre société et les
violences contre les élus sont les mêmes
que contre les gendarmes que contre les
policiers que contre les enseignants que
contre les personnel qui sont ceux des
sapin pompiers ou des médecins c'est
ceux qui représentent la République on
devrait tous être d'accord sur ça et la
mission que vous fait à Monsieur Jumel
sera être écouté par la première
ministre et par le Président de la
République merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien Jumel
pour le groupe
GDR présidente ministre 40 démissions
par mois 40 démissions par mois et le
sentiment pour les maires de France qui
tiennent congrès que l'État les ignore
que l'État quelquefois les méprise un
mépris qui se traduit par l'absence
notable du président Macron à cette
rencontre de tous ceux qui sont le cœur
battant de la République tous les jours
nos élus sont engagés sur le terrain
pour répondre aux exigences de l'État
qui s'accumule et trop souvent nos élus
locaux sont empêchés parfois humiliés
souvent en kquiné plutôt qu'accompagné
pourtant les maires tiennent la baraque
France gilets jaune covid inflation
émeut les maires n'ont pas manqué face
aux crises ils sont restés à porter
d'engueulade sans disposer des moyens
pour répondre aux mots de nos
concitoyens et des outils pour recoudre
une république fracturée dernier rempart
républicain urgentiste d'une France qui
va mal nos Maes ont le moral en berne
l'absence d'un véritable statut pèe
évidemment dans la balance et nous
mettrons avec ma collègue spelbot notre
rapport sur la table pour ouvrir la voie
à un véhicule législatif répondant aux
urgences les protéger face aux violences
évidemment mais pas seulement car les
causes sont nombreuses et plus profondes
aussi depuis trop longtemps la commune
est attaquée fragilisée dans son
autonomie financière malmené par un
déménagement du territoire subi attaquer
la commune c'est attaquer la République
défendre la commune c'est lui donner les
moyens de prendre soin des habitants
moyens financiers pour préserver les
services publics concrètement cela passe
par le renforcement des pouvoirs d'agir
du maire dont la vie doit compter pour
défendre une classe menacée sauver une
maternité aider une famille d'enfants
handicapés ou pour faire face
concrètement à la bande sociale que
représente le logement madame la
ministre le temps vous le savez N pas au
discours ou à la
calinothérapie comment le gouvernement
envistage-t-il au-delà des violences
faites aux élus de faire respecter les
communes merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Sabrina
agrestier roubage secrétaire d'État
chargé de la citoyenneté et de la ville
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
jumell les maires sont au cœur de nos
préoccupations et et des préoccupations
du gouvernement vous le savez ce sont
eux qui InCar la République mett en
œuvre pragmatiquement des solutions de
terrain on y travaille tous les jours ce
sont les premiers à expérimenter adapter
évaluer les politiques publ la démission
d'un maire est toujours une perte dans
les rangs de ceux qui s'engagent pour
l'intérêt général il est demandé au
préfet de suivre chacune de ces
situations
individuellement l'engagement de nos
mères est précieux ils sont en première
ligne du phénomène d'attetinte aux élus
vous avez raison de le rappeler leurs
engagements leur engagement exceptionnel
et mérite une protection exceptionnelle
c'est le fait c'est c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement au travers des dispositifs
spécifiques d'un plan national financé à
hauteur de 5 million d'euros pour 2024
force de sécurité intérieure magistrat
association ont été mobilisés mais il
faut aussi donner au maire des leviers
d'action le gouvernement s'engage à
garantir des dotations financières
pérenes à simplifier les conditions
d'exercice de leur mandat à développer
le droit de dérogation à la main des
préfets au soutien des initiatives
locales la reconnaissance du travail des
maires c'est aussi le travail engagé
autour du statut de l'élu vous-même et
la député violette spilbou avait engagé
ce travail dans le cadre d'une d'une
mission parlementaire la Convention
nationale de la démocratie locale
organisée par Dominique fort ma collègue
et l'AMF s'est tenu le 7 novembre
dernier à vocation à nourrir les les
réflexions qui se sont engagés et qui
sont engagés par l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat il a beaucoup pas faire
c'est vrai sur ces sujets pour renforcer
le rôle des maires et leur donner les
moyens de conduire leur mandat dans des
conditions à la hauteur de leur
engagement vous êtes mobilisés les
associations des l le son nous sommes
mobilisés nous sommes collectivement
mobilisés et nous pouvons réussir
ensemble merci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je suis
heureuse de souhaiter en votre nom la
bienvenue à une délégation de
l'Assemblée nationale de Mauritanie
conduite par Monsieur Sidney sokona
président du groupe d'amitié France
Mauritanie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Didier
Le Maire pour le groupe
horizon merci merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche Thomas 16 ans est décédé à la
suite de ses blessures dans un village
de la Drome après une attaque d'une
violence inouï et sans motif apparents
je veux ici m'associer au nom du groupe
horizon à la douleur de ses proches de
sa famille de ses amis de son
village
nous vivons actuellement en France que
ça soit dans nos villages nos villes une
période de tension sociale et de repli
et cette attaque dans un petit village
du sud de la France ajouter aux autres
difficultés que rencontrent nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens au
quotidien participe au climat anxiogène
dans lequel nous évoluons depuis
quelques mois ce climat c'est aussi
celui d'une violence et d'une pression
toujours plus importante portée sur les
femmes et les hommes qui consacrent leur
vie professionnelle et bien trop souvent
personnelle au service de nos
concitoyens je pense ici aux élus aux
professeurs policiers gendarmes sapeurs
pompiers personnel soignant celles et
ceux qui ont été cités par mes collègues
tout à l'heure la nation a encore
enterré un de ses professeurs il y a
maintenant quelques semaines un maire
sur deux ne souhaite pas se représenter
en
2026 qui va tenir notre nation lorsque
plus personne ne s'engage
dans le vivre ensemble lorsque ces
personnes engagées ou non pour notre
République sont attaquées agressées
caillasser insulter c'est l'intégrité de
notre démocratie toute entière qui
enathtit aussi il est indispensable que
l'État apporte très rapidement des
réponses et des solutions pérennes à
cette situation afin de garantir la
sécurité la tranquillité et le bien
vivre ensemble de toutes et et tous en
France c'est pourquoi j'aimerais savoir
Monsieur le
Ministre pourquoi j'aimerais savoir
Monsieur le Ministre ce que vous comptez
faire pourer handiguer ce phénomène je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à monsieur Éric Dupont Moretti garde
d' saau ministre de la
Justice
monsieur merci merci Madame merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur monsieur le
député le
maire vous irez bientôt en vacances vous
aussi monsieur le
député
allez un peu silence s'il vous plaî
monsieur monsieur le député le
maire
d'abord d'abord d'abord je voudrais
m'associer évidemment au propos de
compassion que vous avez eu à l'égard de
ce gosse qui est mort à l'âge de 16 ans
on pense évidemment tous à sa famille et
je ne doute pas dans quelques instants
certains tenteront d'exploiter de façon
politicienne ce drame
[Applaudissements]
absolu
s'agissant s'agissant des élus j'ai
demandé au procureur de la République
des réponses fermes je ne veux pas me
payer de mots je veux vous annoncer des
chiffres en 2022 le taux de réponse
pénale des action commise contre les
élus s'élève à 98 % contre 94 % en 2017
à gravité égale pour des faits de
violence le taux de prononcé d'un
emprisonnement ferme et de 51 % pour un
quantum de 15,4 mois lorsque la victime
é TR un élu contre 23 % et 8 % en
l'absence de et 8 mois en l'absence de
circonstances aggravantes le taux de
déferement monsieur le député et de 51 %
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une victime qui est
un élu contre 11 % et le taux de mandat
de dépôt le taux de mandat de dépôt est
de 63 % contre 18 % cela confirme
évidemment la prise en considération de
la qualité d'élu par nos juridictions
les uns et les autres peuvent ne pas
être d'accord avec ça on ne fait pas
mentir les chiffres je vous remercie
monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Carlos
Martin bilongo pour le groupe la France
assise madame la Première ministre
depuis les terribles massacrees du 7
octobre 2023 perpétré par le Hamas nous
condamnons avec la plus grande fermeté
les crimes de guerre visant à terroriser
les populations civiles israéliennes
nous condamnons avec la plus grande
fermeté les crimes de guerre et la
Vagance aveugle qu'effectue l'armée
israélienne sur le peuple palestinien le
9 octobre 2023 le ministre israélien de
la Défense YAF Galan a déclaré j'ai
ordonné un siège complet de la bande de
Gaza il n'y aura pas d'électricité pas
de nourriture pas de carburant tout est
fermé nous nous combattons des animaux
humains et nous agisons en conséquen le
Premier ministre Benjamin netanahou a
dit nous ferons de Gaza une île déserte
nous viserons chaque recoin de la bande
de Gaza pourtant la la France a accordé
un soutien inconditionnel à Israël et
depuis 45 jours de conflit voilà le
résultat la bande de Gaza est assiégé du
nord au sud il y a des bombardements
partout l'agence routers et les chips de
l'ONU sont accablant plus de 13000 morts
il y a
5500 enfants qui décèdent dans la bonne
de Gaza
[Musique]
réagissez 40 à 50 % du bâti de la ville
sont complètement détruits 280 écoles
sont
détruites le port de Gaza est détruit et
j'aurai une question madame la Première
ministre la France selon le rapport de
2023 au Parlement les exportions
d'armement de la France auraient vendu
111 millions d'euros d'armes à Israël en
2017 puis 15 milli3 en
2022 outre ces ventes effectif
la France a délivré de nombreuses
licences d'exportation de matériel de
guerre pour
2022 j'aimerais votre réponse madame la
ministre la France continueraelle à
livrer des armes à
Israël je vous remercie la parole est à
Madame Caine colon ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires
étrangères merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Martin bilongo je vis
vous assurer que la position de la
France ne varie pas Israël a subi une
attaque terroriste barbare vous ne
l'ignorez pas et Israël a le droit de se
défendre comme nous-même nous aurions le
droit de nous défendre des otages sont
retenus dans la bande de Gaza dont des
Français nous demandons leur libération
immédiate sans conditions et je suis sûr
que vous pensez aussi à eux monsieur le
député et enfin les Palestiniens les
Palestiniens ne doivent pas payer pour
les crimes du Hamas voilà nos principes
voilà des principes juste et clair ceux
qui sont les nôtres depuis le début
alors oui monsieur le député il y a à
Gaza trop de souffrance et trop de morts
nous l'avons dit clairement et nous
l'avons dit clairement depuis plusieurs
semaines il faut une trêve immédiate
durable pour que davantage d'aide entre
à Gaza pour que les populations civiles
soient protégées et pour que cette trêve
conduise un cesser le feu nous agissons
c'est ce consensus qui s'est forgé à
Paris le 9 no
l de la conférence humanitaire et c'est
aussi la position d'un nombre croissant
de nos
partenaires la France est aussi au
rendez-vous concrètement pour l'aide aux
Palestiniens soutien aux Nations Unies
aide médicale déploiement du porte
hélicoptère d'X mude possibilité ouverte
pour des enfants palestiniens de pouvoir
être soignés en France et je remercie
mon collègue ministre de la Santé voilà
du concret monsieur le député sagissant
des hôpitaux je voudrais en parler ce
sont des sanctuaire ils le sont pour les
Israéliens comme ils le sont pour les
Palestiniens le droit international
interdit formellement de détourner des
hôpitaux à des fins militaires et cela
se produit quant au crime commis par les
colons contre les Palestiniens crimes
trop nombreux nous les condamnons
officiellement et ouvertement mais la
France va plus loin merci Madame la
merci Madame la
minist état
merci monsieur bilongo vous n'avez que 2
secondes madame la ministre l'article s
du TCA interdit la France demande des
armes pour des crimes de guerre merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Lisette
Polet pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
avant de commencer je voudrais avoir une
pensée pour Thomas assassiné dimanche ce
matin je redis mon soutien à ses proches
et à tous les blessés de cette terrible
attaque notre pays est une nouvelle fois
en deuil Thomas 16 an est décédé à
crépool après avoir reçu un coup de
couteau ce meurtre est le témoignage
criant de l'ensauvagement de notre
société notre ruralité n'est désormais
plus épargné par par cette sauvagerie
qui bouleverse des vies et enem brise
d'autres la violence mise en œuvre la
détermination des agresseurs et la
présence de couteau de cuisine
interdisent de qualifier cette équ
équipé sauvage de simple Rix ainsi que
le font certain nombre de médias que des
racailles viennent faire une rasia en
toute impunité est intolérable si des
jeunes agissent comme cela c'est qu'il y
a un réel problème de société Enzo Axel
Anthony et maintenant Thomas la liste
des enfants de France tué gratuitement
est trop longue autant de familles
endillé qui ne comprennent pas que ces
atrocités continuent les mesures pour
combattre cet enzau ne sont pas prises
mais cela ne peut plus durer la France
en a en a assez de voir ses enfants
mourir les Français ne supportent plus
ce terrorisme du quotidien cette
décivilisation qui augmente non monsieur
le ministre cette mort n'est pas un fait
divivers non cette mort et ses blessé ce
n'est pas normal il est urgent et
légitime que nous politiques nous
apportions une réponse pour que les
français bénéficient de la première des
libertés la
sécurité
alors monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour que pour que
cette insécurité dans nos villes et nos
village cesse ce qui nous a ce qui
arrive nous l'avions malheureusement
prédit et les Français souffrent du
manque de fermeté dans la
justice ces jeunes n'ont plus peur de
tuer ils n'ontur ils n'ont plus peur de
la police ils n'ont plus peur de la
justice mais il est temps que la peur
change de camp il est temps que les
sanctions soient enfin appliqué beaucoup
ma cher collègue parole est à Monsieur
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des
outrmes merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée permettez-moi évidemment
également au nom du gouvernement
d'adresser mes condoléances à cette
famille mais aussi aux blessés puisqu'il
y a trois blessés me semble-t-il à
l'hôpital et à leur famille pour le dire
que évidemment ce qui s'est passé voilà
quelques heures est absolument ignoble
inacceptable et et que tous les moyens
de la Gendarmerie nationale ont été mis
et je peux vous annoncer madame que
voilà quelques minutes se interpellés
ont été fait par la gendarmerie
nationale aux environs de Toulouse
l'enquête dira si ce sont les personnes
qui sont l'auteur de ces ce crime odieux
mais nous pouvons penser qu'en effet
rapidement après 70 auditions le
ministère de l'intérieur sous l'autorité
du procureur de la République a pris ça
très au sérieux et que ces personnes
seraient celles qui sont évidemment
aujourd'hui accusé de l' par la
gendarmerie nationale interpellé et
j'espère qu'il son condamné après une
enquête bien évidemment au plus dur
peine par notre justice je veux dire
madame la députée que le travail que
nous faisons policiers et gendarmes
partout sur le territoire national dans
les villes comme dans les campagne est
un travail admirable et oui j'ai été le
premier à dire madame la députée j'ai
été le premier à dire que le travail des
policiers et des gendarmes est un
travail difficile qu'il nous faut
soutenir et qu'il faut éviter au moment
où connaissez ni l'âge des personnes qui
ont été interpellé ni leur nationalité
ni le
ni ni comment cela s passé évitez madame
évitez madame de rajouter de l'indignité
à un drame qui touche toute la
[Applaudissements]
nation je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Emmanuel
Antoine pour le groupe les
républicains
ce weekend dans la nuit du 18 au 19
novembre dans ma circonscription la vie
d'un adolescent de 16 ans a été emporté
Thomas a succombé au coups qui lui ont
été infligé ce jeune avait toute une vie
devant lui il lui restait tout à vivre
ses joies ses amours ses peines ses
espoirs tout cela lui a été enlevé
Thomas avait une famille des parents
aimants des amis proche c'est vers eux
que vont mes pensées Thomas n'a pas eu
droit à une minute de silence je tiens
donc à lui rendre hommage dans cette
hémicycle temple de notre République
pour que la représentation nationale
témoigne unanimement de son soutien
envers sa
famille
ce weekend une bande de jeunes a fait
éruption dans un moment festif pour en
découdre lors d'un bal organisé par le
comité des fêtes de la commune de Crépol
ils ont violemment attaqué à l'arme
blanche les participants de cette soirée
16 autres personnes ont été blessées et
deux sont en urgence absolue à l'issue
de ce drame je leur adresse tout mon
soutien pour tous les jeunes présents ce
qui devait être un un moment de fête a
finalement été le mouroir de leur
insouciance juvénile pour tous les
participants la convivialité de cet
événement a effroyablement laissé place
au deuil et à la désolation que partage
tout notre territoire la violence a
encore frappé dans notre pays cette
violence qui ne cesse de meurtrir et
d'endeuiller cette violence qui
gangrainene tout et que l'on ne parvient
pas à en rayer nous devons unanimement
la condamner notre République doit être
forte oui elle doit avoir les moyens de
faire face aux agresseurs et se montrer
ferme dans ses condamnations pour que
des VI cessent d'être Ôé des familles
entières d'être endeuillé et pour que
nos jeunes puissent vivre leur jeunesse
tout
simplement merci beaucoup ma ch collègue
la parole est à Monsieur é duoretti
garde vaau ministre de la
Justice merci madame la Présidente merci
madame la députée Antoine
pour la mesure dont vous avez fait
preuve en posant cette question
oui la vie enlevée de ce gosse de 16 ans
méritait à l'évidence un moment de
silence et de recueillement il a
immédiatement été substitué par un
moment de polémique j'ai noté d'ailleurs
que dans la question j'ai noté
d'ailleurs que dans la question
précédente on évoquait m de il n'y a pas
de hasard il n'y a que des rendez-vous
les rendez-vous du malheur que vous
honorez qu'il s'agisse de la petite Lola
qu'il s'agisse du petit Clément une
dernière chose sil vous plaî s'il vous
plaît une dernière
chose les auteurs de ces fait seront
jugés par une cour
d'assise compos d'un jur populaire comme
le sont tous les crimes deang ce sont
des Français comme vous comme moi qui
rendront la justice qui n'est pas
l'xiste qui est sévère de plus en plus
sévère depuis 20
ans je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
madame madame Antoine s'il vous plaît
monsieur lecardesso j'espère que oui la
justice sera à la hauteur merci beaucoup
madame la
députée
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Fed
pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les députés le 8
novembre dans l'héros Sonia a été
mortellement poignardée à 26 reprises
par son mari le 15 novembre dans la
Somme c'est Sonia qui a été battu à mort
par son compagnon à leur domicile mais
c'est aussi CLA Madison Irène Juliana
ainsi que Séverine ou encore édite ces 6
dernières semaines 93 femmes ont perdu
la vie en raison de féminicide depuis le
début de l'année 93 pert tragique je
tiens à avoir une pensée pour chacune
d'entre
elles ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre Beranger cuillard en 2022 plus
de 240000 personnes ont été victimes de
violen commise par leur partenair ou
soit une hausse de plus de 15 % par
rapport à
2021 si ces chiffres restent
particulièrement inquiétants ils sont
également révélateurs d'une libération
verbale une prise en compte plus
importante de la parole des femmes les
violences sont multiformes pour
certaines elles ne sont même pas perçues
comme telles c'est la base du travail
réalisé sur mon territoire par les
jeunes du lycée professionnel julverne
d'étable surmer qui sont présents ce
mardi dans
l'hémicycle ils ont créé un
violentomètre à taille humaine qui a été
inauguré ce midi à l'Assemblée nationale
je tenais madame la Présidente à vous
remercier d'avoir soutenu cette
initiative cet outil d'autoévaluation
permet de repérer les comportements
déviants et de mesurer si le si la
relation est basée sur le consentement
et ne comporte pas de violence cette
initiative nous invite toutes et tous à
réfléchir sur la qualité de notre
rapport à
l'autre chers collègues samedi marquera
la Journée internationale pour
l'élimination des violences à l'égard
des femmes alors que la mobilisation
grandit d'année en année alors que
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
a été déclarée grande cause du quinquena
les moyens de lutter contre ce fléo
doivent être à la hauteur madame la
ministre je connais votre mobilisation
sur ces sujets essentiel la
représentation nationale et les Français
attendent des actes forts pour les mois
à venir pouvez-vous nous présenter votre
stratégie de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes merci beaucoup mon
cher collègue la parole est à Madame
berangard Couillard ministre chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et de la lutte contre les
discriminations merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député phppe fait
déjà je tenais à vous remercier pour
l'initiative que vous avez lancé avec
les lycéens du lycée juleverne deétaples
sur mer pour cette initiative avec
madame la Présidente nous étions ravis
de pouvoir l'inaugurer et c'est
évidemment un travail de sensibilisation
qu'il est indispensable de mener et je
vous remercie parce que ça permet de
rappeler que il suffit d'une bousculade
il suffit d'une claque pour que les
violences adviennent rappelez que nous
agissons de depuis maintenant 2019 avec
le Grenel des violences conjugales cinq
lois ont été votées ici dans cet
hémicycle et également nous avons mis en
place de nombreux dispositifs le recueil
de la parole des femmes d'abord avec
l'extension de la ligne téléphonique
3919 24h sur 24 16 jours sur 7 nous
avons également formé des policiers et
des gendarmes 150000 policiers gendarmes
ont été formés et 100 % de nos élèves
issus des écoles de police et
gendarmerie le sont nous avons également
fait en sorte de déployer des des
dispositifs qui permettent de protéger
les femmes c'est quoi ce sont des
bracelets antiapprochement plus de 1000
des téléphones graves danger également
plus de 5000 qui sont aujourd'hui
déployés et puis nous avons sensiblement
augmenté les places d'hébergement
d'urgence nous avons multiplié par deux
ils sont aujourd'hui au nombre de 10000
en 2023 nous continuons nous continuons
avec également la le traitement des
auteurs parce que sans auteur il n'y a
pas de victime nous souhaitons agir sur
la récidive nous avons ouvert 30 centres
de pris en charge des auteurs de
violence conjugale ils sont accompagnés
psychologiquement également à la
réinsertion à l'emploi et aussi au
traitement des addictions parce qu'il
n'est pas rare de trouver dans le cadre
de violence au sein du couple des
personnes qui sont sous le coup de
l'alcoolémie ou de ou de différentes
drogues mais évidemment nous ne sommes
pas satisfaits des résultats vous savez
beaucoup de de choses sont encore à
faire la mise en place évidemment des
ordonnances de protection en 24 heures
les pôles de spécialisés ou encore le
pack nouveau départ mer beaucou madame
la ministre merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame la
vice-présidente Rabo pour le groupe
socialiste
merci merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres je
ne sais pas trop à qui je vais poser la
question du coup mais la pénurie de
médicaments connaît un nouveau pic en
France et selon l'Agence nationale de la
sécurité du médicament il manque
aujourd'hui de
laamoxyiline du sulbatamol pour contre
l'asthme du coca essentiel comme
métablocant du crayon prescrit à ceux
qui n'ont plus de pancréas et encore
beaucoup d'autres médicaments
indispensable à la vie on est passé de
700 médicaments en pénurie en 2018 à
plus de 3700 en 2022 alors vous me direz
tous les pays en Europe connaissent des
difficultés c'est vrai mais la France
est le pays qui en Europe connaît le
plus de difficultés et le plus de
pénuries depuis 4 ans vous avez annoncé
au gouvernement plusieurs plans qui
n'ont eu aucun effet sur
l'approvisionnement en médicaments vous
dites d'un côté vouloir relocaliser et
de l'autre vous ne dites absolument rien
quand Sanofi qui produit aujourd'hui 70
% du paracétamol a annoncé fin octobre
vendre son usine en France vous ne vous
êtes absolument pas soucié de savoir si
la production de paracétamol resterait
en France la seule chose que vous faites
dans le budget de la sécurité social
vous mettez des franchises sur les
boîtes de médicaments que les Français
ne peuvent même plus se procurer alors
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
donnez-moi deux mesures pour faire en
sorte de réduire les pénuries de
médicaments je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau
ministre de la santé et de la
prévention madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la la
Présidente nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une situation de tension sur
l'approvisionnement de certains
médicaments mais qui n'est pas la même
situation que l'an dernier aujourd'hui
sur le territoire national notamment
après la la la saison extrêmement
difficile de l'année dernière nous avons
les stocks qui permettent sur les
médicaments que vous avez cité je ne
parle pas là des médicaments innovants
où nous rencontrons les mêmes
difficultés que les autres pays d'Europe
nous avons les stocks ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est une dérégulation
complète du système de distribution avec
il faut mettre les mots sur les réalités
avec par certains acteurs qui veulent
profiter du système pour assurer de la
rentabilité
aujourd'hui j'ai demandé là j'ai réuni
tous les acteur de la filière du
médicament il y a maintenant 8 jours
demain demain je serai en mesure
d'annoncer demain je serai en mesure
d'annoncer que les différents acteurs de
la chaîne industriel grossistes
répartiteurs et pharmaciens se sont mis
d'accord pour stopper la dérive qui
consistait notamment pour certaines
pharmacies à acheter directement auprès
des industriels ce qui conduisait à
favoriser les plus grosses pharmacies
par rapport aux petites pharmacies
notamment les pharmacies rurales nous
reviendrons à une régulation normale et
dans le PLFSS madame la Présidente vous
l'avez sans doute noté nous proposons
également de renforcer les compétences
de police sanitaire de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament pour
que précisément dans un cas comme
celui-ci nous ne soyons pas forcément
obligés de passer par la bonne volonté
des acteurs même avec la pression du
gouvernement mais que nous ayons des
mesures directes de police sanitaire
pour prendre le dessus sur certains sur
certaines pratiques qui ne sont pas
acceptables je vous remerci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre madame
Rabo oui merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre moi j'ai deux
demandes sur l'obligation de constituer
des stocks de 2 à 4 mois vous n'avez
fait aucun contrôle il y a eu zéro
sanction en 2021 et 3 en 2022 pour
300000 € sur un budget total de 24
milliards d'euros je vous demande de
faire appliquer des sanctions et face
aux pénuries les plus graves je vous
demande aussi d'assumer votre rôle de
puissance publique et d'organiser une
production minimale dans les hôpitaux ce
que prévoit l'article 3 que vous ne
mettez pas en œuvre aujourd'hui merci ma
cher
collègu la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane rambau pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente mes
propos s'adressent à Madame la Ministre
chargée des collectivités territoriales
et de la ruralité alors que s'ouvre à
Paris le traditionnel salon des Maires
et des Collectivités permettez-moi
d'aborder deux problématiques qui
impactent l'avenir de nos démocraties
locales depuis plusieurs années nous
assistons à une augmentation des
violences envers les élus locaux
particulièrement les maires en 2022 le
ministère de l'Intérieur a signaler une
hausse de 32 % de ces violences ces
actes variant de l'intimidation verbale
à des agressions physiques mettent en
lumière la vulnérabilité croissante des
élus et ceci sans concret du
gouvernement parallèlement les problèmes
financiers s'accumulent des décisions
unilatérale tel que la suppression non
compensée de la taxe d'habitation
mettent en péril les finances des
communes madame la ministre dans votre
interview du ojdd du 19 novembre vous
avez déclaré les maires doivent faire
des efforts mais les maires sont déjà
contraints de gérer avec des ressources
de plus en plus limitées et cette
situation pèse sur les épaules des élus
qui reçoivent les indemnités les plus
modestes à cela s'ajoute le retrait
progressif de compétences essentielles
aux communes comme illustré par le cas
de la ville de lacro dans ma
circonscription du Var où le PLU pour
construire une clinique a été
unilatéralement mise à l'arrêt par la
métropole ceci contre le gré de cette
commune et sans l'avoir officiellement
informé alors que le maire avait lancé
la révision ces contraintes allié à
l'insécurité croissante ont conduit
après de 1500 démissions de maire depuis
2020 et des centaines de communes
pourrai manquer de candidats au prochain
municipal
beaucoupvez plus de temps
monè la parole est à Madame Sabrina
grach ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté de la
ville merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député
rambau travailler en confiance ne veut
pas dire être d'accord sur tout vous le
conséderez mais en tout cas moi pour
dans ma méthode dans ce que je dis à
chaque fois beaucoup de vos collègues
m'interpellent et je n'ai jamais hésiter
à concerter à écouter à entendre et oui
c'est la méthode du gouvernement écouter
concerter avec les élus locaux
entretenir un lien direct renforcé vous
en des plais avec celles et ceux qui
incarnent la République la réalité c'est
que vous me posez une question qui m'a
été posée tout à
l'heure au Congrès des Maires au Congrès
des Maires et où j'ai été interpellé
j'ai été interpellé par un élu qui
m'expliquait que dans sa commune tel
direction n'avait pas été prise et je
lui disais ben écoutez sur les cités
éducatives si dans votre collectivité
territoriale dans votre commune vous
estimez dans votre conseil municipal que
c'est pas une bonne c'est pas une bonne
mesure à prendre ou c'est pas une bonne
je finis et c'est pas que c'est pas une
bonne direction l'État ne peut pas se
substituer à tout on se connait on vient
du sud tous les deux vous ne pouvez pas
incriminer tout le temps l'état de tout
la taxe d'habitation a été compensée
vous le savez ça a été voté l'année
dernière et la réalité c'est que je fais
partie de ces ministres de ces ministres
qui ont été comme vous sur ces bancs
députés ma porte est ouverte à chaque
fois celle de ma de de ma collègue
Dominique fort aussi celle du ministre
de l'intérieur aussi vous savez
m'interpeller m'écrire j'encourage tous
les députés de cet hémicycle à le faire
parce que vous avez systématiquement une
réponse un oui un non une réponse
directe et jamais je me dérobe et le
gouvernement encore moins je vous
remercie monsieur le merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Valter
pour le groupe
LFI merci madame la
Présidente madame la secrétaire d'État à
l'enfance le 1er août 2020 votre
prédécesseur annoncé la création d'une
commission sur les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants centré sur la
question de l'inceste le 23 janvier 2021
2 semaines après l'apparution du livre
de Camille Kouchner Emmanuel Macron
s'adressé en ces termes aux victimes le
silence construit par les criminels et
les lâchetés successives enfin explose
il explose grâce au courage de celles et
ceux qui témoignent ces témoignages ces
paroles parfois ses cris plus personne
ne peut les ignorer et c'est aujourd'hui
à nous d'agir le 11 mars la civise était
installée avec une feuille de route pour
2 ans bientôt 3 au cours de ces presque
3 années elle a recueilli près de 30000
témoignages auprès de victimes dont la
première phrase était souvent j'ai
attendu ce moment toute ma vie pour se
confier il faut avoir confiance la
civise a su devenir cette personne de
confiance qui s'incarne pour les
victimes les collectifs pour le grand
public dans la figure du juge Édouard
Durand or depuis plusieurs mois
l'incertitude pèse sur le devenir de la
civise son mandat sera-t-il prolongé
sous quelle forme et avec qui à sa tête
alors qu'aucune annonce officielle n'est
venue répondre à ses inquiétudes vous
avez déclaré il y a 3 jours dans la
presse je souhaite que le travail de la
civise continue avec une nouvelle
feuille de route mais hier lundi 20
novembre journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant alors que la CIVIS
présentait son rapport et qu'avait lieu
le comité interministériel à l'enfance
on n'en savait pas plus madame la
secrétaire d'État confirmez-vous que la
civise sera maintenue avec quelle
feuille de route et le juge dur rang
pourra-t-il poursuivre sa mission comme
c'est le souhait manifeste de l'ensemble
des associations et des centaines de
personnes réunies hier le 23 janvier
2021 Emmanuel Macron concluit par ses
mots on vous écoute on vous croit vous
ne serez plus jamais seul dimanche vous
avez également déclaré nous avons encore
une révolution à accomplir pour protéger
nos enfants je suis d'accord avec vous
vos réponses diront
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Charlotte cobel ministre en charge de
l'enfance merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Léo Valter nous l'avons dit je
le répète aujourd'hui le gouvernement
souhaite que le travail de la CIVIS
continue avec des modalités et une
feuille de route renouvelée et centré
sur de nouvelles missions nous en
présenterons le détail avec le gardess
saau dans les toutes prochaines semaines
il faut dire que nous avons reçu à 5
ministre le rapport de 4 de 750 pages et
de 82 recommandations vendredi dernier
je comprends votre impatience mais vous
comprenez aussi qu'il nous faut un peu
de temps pour étudier les choses cette
CIVIS vous l'avez dit c'est le président
de la République qui l'a voulu c'est le
président de la République qui l'a
soutenu le gouvernement l'a soutenu
depuis qu'elle a été m en place et le
gouvernement l'a écouté hier nous avons
présenté tous ensemble nous étions 12
minutes ministres autour de la première
ministre à porter un plan audacieux de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
enfants dans la suite d'un plan qui
avait déjà été conduit depuis 2019 dans
ce plan énormément de choses ont été
repris des préconisations de la civise
c'est vous dire que nous avons écouté la
civise nous avons écouté la civise moi
je suis moins écouté que la civise
manifestement parce qu'elle a recueilli
des des témoignages tout à fait
importants qui nous ont permis d'évaluer
l'impact de ces violences sur les
enfants c'est grâce à cela que nous
pouvons porter un combat un combat
collectif qui n'est pas le combat d'un
homme mais qui est le combat d'un
gouvernement qui est le combat d'un
parlement qui doit être le combat de T
les adultes de ce pays pour éradiquer ce
fléo nous présenterons les modalités et
la feuille de route dans les quelques
jours je comprends votre impatience ça
fait des des millénaires que nous
attendons cela la Révolution elle est en
marche laissez-nous l'agir avec fermeté
c'est un discours de responsabilité et
pas de
polémique merci beaucoup madame
ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente Goulet pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur le ministre il est
de notre devoir en tant que société de
veiller à la protection au bien-être de
nos enfants ils sont les piliers de
notre avenir votre ministère et ses
agents jouent chaque jour un rôle majeur
pour leur pour les enfants et leur
devenir mais une telle politique est
forcément interministérielle tant elle
nécessite la mobilisation de tous les
ministères l'éducation nationale les
ministères sociaux la santé l'intérieur
la justice bien évidemment mais
également le sport la culture l'emploi
l'économie l'enseignement supérieur il
faut toute une société pour élever un
enfant hier à l'occasion du comité
interministériel à l'enfance que vous
avez fait autour de Charlotte cobel
ministre de l'enfance et de ellisabeth B
première ministre vous avez participé à
la présentation de la réponse du
gouvernement en faveur des
enfants je ne peux que saluer puisque je
le porte depuis de longs mois votre
volonté d'action en faveur d'une
véritable éducation au corps à la
sexualité et à la bienveillance parmi
les réponses que vous avez apporté il y
a nécessairement la place de l'école qui
dans vos annonces effectue une véritable
révolution celle du soutien à la
réussite et à l'ambition scolairire des
enfants protégés quand ces enfants sont
protégés accueillis 4 difficulté
familiale ou victime de violence l'école
doit devenir une bouée à laquelle ils
doivent se raccrocher or ce que l'on
voit c'est que 61 % des adolescents de
15 ans placés en établissement sont
toujours dans un niveau relevant du
premier cycle voire un niveau
élémentaire que seulement 20 %
obtiennent un baccalauréat général sans
parler de tous ceux qui quittent le
système sans diplôme avec de fait une
promesse de difficile insertion alors
monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous nous
détailler ce que contient le nouveau
dispositif scolarité protégée que vous
avez annoncé hier pour que enfin demain
notre République soit la chance des
enfants protégés merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Atal
ministre de l'éducation national et de
la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente
Goulet la vulnérabilité a plusieurs
visages et le rôle de l'éducation
nationale c'est bien d'accompagner tous
les enfants et évidemment les plus
vulnérables d'entre eux vous l'avez dit
nous étions réunis hier autour de la
première ministre et de Charlotte cobel
pour ce comité interministériel à
l'enfance et ce que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'y présenter et nous y avons beaucoup
travaillé avec Charlotte cobel ces
derniers mois c'est la mise en place
d'une véritable scolarité protégée pour
les enfants protéger les enfants placé
très concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire une simplification drastique
de toutes les procédures administratives
pour lutter contre le décrochage
scolaire et on sait malheureusement que
toutes les procédures peuvent entraîner
un certain nombre de décrochage et
qu'ensuite c'est des vulnérabilités
supplémentaires deuxième chose quand
malheureusement le décrochage survient
la mise en place d'un suivi renforcé
notamment en lien avec le knned pour
permettre à ces enfants à ses élèves de
continuer de poursuivre leur scolarité
troème élément des entretiens
d'orientation désormais systématique mis
en place pour tous ces enfants à la fin
du collège et à 17 ans qui doivent être
systématisés et surtout pour qu'on soit
plus efficace c'est insupportable ce que
vous faites insupportable et pour que ce
soit plus efficace pour que ce soit plus
efficace pour les enfants des référents
désignés pour coordonner l'action de
tous les acteurs des rectorats des
services départementaux de l'éducation
nationale et les services de l'AZ c'est
donc une mise en commun de tous les
acteurs pour renforcer notre efficacité
on dirait
nous sa et vous l'z les vulnérabilités
peuvent s'ajouter et malheureusement on
le voit ce sont des enfants qui ont
quatre fois plus de risque d'accumuler
les retards en primaire quatre fois plus
de risque de décrocher ensuite dans leur
scolarité et donc nous devons être
encore plus impliqués encore plus à leur
côté pour leur permettre de réussir
puisque comme vous l'avez dit ils ont le
droit de réussir à l'école de la
République ils ont le droit de bâtir
leur destin dans l'école de la
République ils ont le droit d'être
ambition pour d'être ambitieux pour
eux-même et nous sommes ambieux pour eux
merci la parole est à Madame Catherine
Jaouen pour le rassemblement national
allez c'est
parti madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues madame la ministre déléguée
chargée des personnes handicapées de
France le 23 novembre 2023 se tiendra la
mise en fonction de la plateforme du ha
que vous avez massivement plébiscité je
cite la promotion de l'emploi des
personnes handicapées constitue une des
priorités politiques du gouvernement
vous rappelez également la mise en place
de mesures fortes pour accompagner les
personnes handicapées vers l'emploi mais
qu'en est-il au sein même du ministère
de l'Éducation nationale alors où nous
manquons de professeurs on peut
s'interroger sur le fait que l'éducation
nationale ne remplisse pas ses quotas
fixés à 6 % d'emploi réservé aux
personnes handicapées l'éducation
nationale préfère s'acquiter de
pénalités auprès du fond pour
l'insertion des personnes handicapé au
sein de la fonction publique pour une
somme qui à ce jour atteint les 31 8
millions d'euros alors que l'éducation
nationale a dépensé seulement 6,3
millions d'euros en frais de
fonctionnement pour son personnel
handicapé en 2022 le calcul est simple C
fois plus d'argent dépensé dans les
pénalités plutôt que dans des
investissements concret vous avez fait
le choix de pousser les personnes
handicapées faire la sortie j'ai reçu
récemment une agrégée une normalienne
qui suite à une maladie lourde c'est qui
qui a détérioré son état physique a
provoqué un handicap de 50 % et elle a
donc été orienté vers le knned puis son
handicap physique s'est alourdé à 80 %
et elle reste néanmoins en pleine
possession de ses moyens intellectuel et
souhaite continuer à enseigner alors que
la loi de 84 prévoit que le poste de
travail d'un fonctionnaire handicapé
soit adapté vous n'en faites rien
prenant le cas que je vous cité il
aurait été possible de proposer un
maintien Ned un poste en présentiel
adapté ou en distantiel elle est mise au
Reus son cas tranché mise en retraite
anticipée fin de l'histoire comment
pouvez-vous donc prétendre dans même
temps faire du handicap une priorité
nationale et en même temps condamner
femmes et hommes qui veulent travailler
sous prétexte de leur invalidité que
comptez-vous donc faire pour répondre au
sous-emploi des personnes handicapées
dans l'éducation nationale je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Gabriel Atal ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Jaouen l'éducation nationale
c'est le premier employeur de France
c'est même le premier employeur d'Europe
ça lui donne évidemment d'immenses
responsabilités notamment en matière
d'inclusion des personnes en situation
de handicap est-ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui au niveau auquel nous
devrions être dans l'éducation nationale
s'agissant de l'accueil de personnes en
situation de handicap dans le corps
enseignants et dans les personnels la
réponse est non nous avons évidemment
des agents en situation de handicap près
de 40000 au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et je veux leur rendre hommage
ils sont au côté de nos élèves ils font
partie de la communauté éducative ils
apportent temps à notre école et à nos
élèves mais évidemment nous devons aller
plus loin nous devons pouvoir accueillir
davantage d'enseignants de personnel de
santé sociaux de direction personnel
administratif en situation de handicap à
l'éducation nationale on y travaille
beaucoup avec mon collègue Stanislas
Guerini c'est un objectif transversal
dans la fonction publique avec
évidemment Fadila katabi ce que je peux
vous dire sur les actions qui sont
engagé d'abord nous avons développé une
politique ambitieuse de d'allègement de
servicees et de poste adapté très
concrètement un professeur en situation
de handicap peut se voir proposer un
service allégé d'un/ers tout en étant
rémunéré à temps complet c'est une
possibilité qui existe qui est déjà
offerte à un certain nombre
d'enseignants en situation de handicap
ensuite nous avons constitué un réseau
de conseillers de proximité et mis en
place des parcours professionnels en
faveur des personnels bénéficiaires de
l'obligation d'emploi pour mieux
accompagner leurs évolutions
professionnelles il y a un plan
quinquenal 2023-2027 qui a été constitu
pour aller encore plus loin notamment
dans la simplification des démarches
administratives vous l'avez dit ça peut
être cafcayen un certain nombre de
situations et je suis très preneur de
l'exemple concret que vous avez évoqué
pour que je puisse regarder très
concrètement ce qui s'est passé et qu'on
en tire des enseignements il y a aussi
beaucoup à faire encore sur la lutte
contre les discriminations et l'accueil
des personnels en situation de handicap
nous allons continuer à agir sur ce
sujetl vous le voyez nous ne sommes pas
au résultats auquel nous devrions être
mais nous allons continuer à avancer mon
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Madame Christine
lonabour pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à la ministre
déléguée chargée des personnes
handicapées madame la ministre la 27e
édition de la Semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées a
débuté hier avec pour thématique la
transition numérique un accélérateur
pour l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap permettez-moi de profiter de
cette question pour remercier le
ministre Olivier du sopte et son cabinet
pour leur remarquable travail en faveur
de l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap pendant et à l'issue de la
Conférence nationale du handicap en lien
avec votre ministère 17 mesures
nouvelles ont été énoncées dont
certaines intégrées dans le projet de
loi plein emploi pour lequel j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être corrapporteur ce texte
vise à rendre l'environnement
professionnel de droit commun accessible
quel que soit le handicap il confie au
service public de l'emploi
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
en situation de handicap il favorisent
leur orientation profess n et leur
maintien dans l'emploi le taux de
chômage des personnes en situation
d'hicap est passé de 19 % à 12 % depuis
2017 c'est encore trop le nombre
d'apprentis a été multiplié par 3 c'est
mieux mais il reste encore beaucoup à
faire cette semaine est une nouvelle
opportunité de sensibiliser la société
et les employeurs le duod qui a lieu ce
jeudi est le temps fort de cette semaine
et participe à changer le regard sur le
handicap au cours de cette journée une
entreprise une collectivité ou une
association peut accueillir une personne
en situation de handicap et former un
duo avec un professionnel volontaire
au-delà de la rencontre elle permet de
créer des vocations mais aussi de faire
naître des opportunités de collaboration
future Madame la Ministre pouvez-vous
nous rappeler les mesures spécifiques
prises par le gouvernement pour
promouvoir l'emploi des personnes en
situation de handicap encourager
l'inclusion notamment au travers de
l'accessibilité numérique et
sensibiliser les entreprises aux
avantages de la diversité dans le monde
professionnel je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole est
à Madame Mame Fadila catabi ministre en
charge des personnes handicapées merci
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
lenabour je tiens tout d'abord à saluer
l'ensemble de votre travail sur le sujet
vous l'avez rappelé l'importance de la
semaine européenne pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées que nous avons
inauguré hier avec le ministre Olivier
du sopt et au cours de laquelle a lieu
cette année effectivement le dieu au
j'en profite pour saluer d'ailleurs la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des députés
pour la 6e édition de cet événement qui
est un événement effectivement très
important et qui est un franc succès en
effet les chiffres parlent de même
26360 duo sont confirmés pour ce jeudi
soit 27 % de plus que l'année dernière
donc vraiment c'est un succès l'année
dernière 23 % des candidats qui sont
passés par le dispositif ont eu une
opportunité professionnelle cette
journée effectivement essentielle car
elle contribue a changer le regard sur
le handicap l'engagement de notre
gouvernement va encore plus loin avec
mon collègue Olivier duopt avec qui je
travaille beaucoup vous l'avez compris
nous avons porté au travers de du projet
de loi pour le plein emploi que vous
avez voté donc la semaine dernière des
mesures concrètes pour renforcer
l'accompagnement et l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes en
situation de handicap désormais ce qui
prévaut c'est le droit commun et
j'insiste là-dessus elles seront toutes
accompagné par le service public de
l'emploi pour élaborer leur projets
professionnels tout en faisant
davantage favorisant pardon davantage
les passerelles vers le milieu ordinaire
grâce à cette politique ambitieuse nous
aidons nos entreprise à se tourner vers
de nouvelles candidatures qui
correspondent aux compétences quelles
recherch notamment dans les métiers en
tension on a envie de leur dire les
talents sont là il suffit de regarder
autour de soi enfin l'insertion dans
l'emploi passe aussi par plus
d'acessibilité notamment numérique
demain en Conseil des ministres le
gouvernement présentera la ratification
des ordonnances relative à la mise en
accessibilité des Sit du service public
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Louis Boyard pour le groupe la France
insoumise madame la Présidente ce
vendredi à villecren dans ma
circonscription un homme a failli mourir
je l'ai eu au téléphone hier et voici ce
qu'il m'a dit avant même de me parler de
la souffrance et du traumatisme d'avoir
reçu un coup de cutteur de 15 cm dans sa
gorge et après avoir subi des insultes
racistes il m'a dit cela fait 3 jours
que j'ai subi un crime raciste et que
personne ne parle de moi mais si jamais
moi Mourad j'avais été l'ingresseur
alors BFM TV et C news auraient déjà été
en bas de ma maison qu'est-ce que cela
dit de l'ambiance qui règne actuellement
dans notre pays il ne se passe pas une
journée sans que sur les débats
télévisés il soit sous-entendu qu'il y
aurait trop de musulmans dans notre pays
ou qu'il serait incompatible avec la
République il ne se passe pas une année
sans que vos lois sur l'immigration
stigmatis les personnes noires et Arabes
et les rendent responsables de tous les
problèmes dans notre pays voilà des
décennies que votre classe politique
épouse les thèses du rassemblement
national et stigmatise nos concitoyennes
et nos concitoyens qui vivent en France
travaillent en France et quel que soit
il sont n on le droit à l'égalité en
France Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Intérieur je vous ai entendu dire que
vous attendiez de connaître la
nationalité des personnes qui ont commis
un meurtre à sép monsieur vous les
ministres vous les députés macronistes
vous les députés du rassemblement
national vos mots ont des conséquences
vos lois ont des conséquences vous
cultivez les préjugés xénophob et les
guerres de religion vous le faites par
électoralisme parfois partion arrive la
loi immigration alors je le répète vos
mots auront des conséquences vos votes
auront des conséquences quel est votre
but ministre collègues rassembleer le
pays ou le diviser et si vous êtes prêt
à le diviser jusqu'où êtes-vous prêt à
aller dans l'abject et dans la
violence je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur géraldan ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
outres merci madame la Présidente mdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Boyard en effet le 17 novembre à
14h à villecess à villecen pardon
excusez-moi dans le valdeemarne dans
votre département d'élection un homme a
été agressé et au nom d'insulte raciste
salale bounoule c'est ce qui a été dit
et je veux ici bien sûr non seulement
les condamner mais je l'ai fait
publiquement vous avez sans doute oublié
de le dire dans votre intervention comme
je le fais à chaque fois que l'on touche
un français un être humain sur le
territoire national et contrairement à
vous je n'essentialise pas je suis là
pour protéger toutes les personnes comme
tous les policiers et les gendarmes quel
que soit leur religion quel que soit
leur prénom quel que soit leur
nationalité l'auteur est en effet un
français de 76 ans
multiécidiviste Monsieur le Député
dégradation refus d'obtempérer outrage à
policier injure publique en raison de la
race de la religion et il a été
interpellé par les effectifs courageux
de la bque que vous voulez supprimer par
ailleurs et je vis remercier la police
nationale alors
oui alors oui mesdames et messieurs les
députés si l'on pouvait regarder les
personnes pour ce qu'ils font et non pas
pour ce qu'ils sont ni les définir par
leur r par le religion supposé pas leur
prénom si on pouvait simplement regarder
ce qui respectent les règles de la
République
l'extrme gauche comme à l'extrême droite
si on pouvait attaquer les récidivistes
à l'extrême gauche comme à l'extrême
droite si on pouvait du même mot
monsieur le député remercier les
policiers quand ils arrêtent ceux qui
attaquent les juifs les musulmans les
chrétiens alors oui monsieur le député
on aura apaisé la situation parce qu'il
n'y a que des hommes il n'y a que des
hommes qui doiv être condamnés par ce
qu'ils font il n'y a que des Français
qui reconnus par mérite je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur Boyard
vous avez 4 secondes vous voulez apaiser
le pays cessz de vous comporte comme un
ministre du Front
[Applaudissements]
national la
parole
allez la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
panifous pour le groupe lot un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît on écoute
l'orateur
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
Monsieur panifous Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègue
ma question s'adresse à Madame la
Ministre des solarités et des familles
soignants personnes âgées et familles
nous alertent quoti quotidiennement sur
la crise majeure que traversent nos
épades le président de la République
lui-même au cours des deux précédentes
campagnes présidentielles avait
clairement affiché ses ambitions pour
créer les conditions d'un accompagnement
digne de nos aînés que ce soit à
domicile ou établissement il s'est alors
engagé à porter une réforme ambitieuse à
la hauteur des ententes des Françaises
et des Français une des mesures
importantes affirmé par le Président de
la République lui-même était la création
de 50000 postes de soignant en épad
avant la fin de ce quinquena en 2027
c'est en effet une réponse très concrète
pour celles et ceux qui vivent en épad
pour celles et ceux qui travaillent les
conditions de travail épad sont en effet
très difficiles l'accompagnement de nos
aînés les plus dépendants n'est pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'attendent nos
concitoyens c'est pour cela que
l'engagement de créer en moyenne entre 6
et 7 postes soit de soignant par épad
est pertinent et nécessaire alors il
faut pour cela former plus de soignants
bien sûr mais il faut aussi redonner
confiance à toutes ces êtres soignantes
toutes ces infirmières qui ont quitté
leur métier parce qu'il était trop dur
épuisé de ne pouvoir accompagner ou
soigner nos aînés dans la dignité nous
pouvons le faire nous pouvons les faire
revenir il sont si nombreux il faut pour
cela un choc de confiance créer ces
postes est un choc de confiance alors ma
question est simple madame la ministre
j'ai pu lire des déclarations qui
laissaient entendre un report de cet
engagement du Président de la République
ce serait à mes yeux un renoncement
alors que nous étudions actuellement la
loi bien vieillir dans l'ombre d'une
autre promesse qui était la grande loi
autonomie pouvez-vous nous confirmer
aujourd'hui que l'engagement du
président de la République sera respecté
que ces 50000 postes promis seront bien
créés avant la fin du quinquena je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Madame aura berger ministre des
Solidarités et des
familles merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député panifous vous vous
avez parlé de choc de confiance donc je
vais reprendre vos termes parce que
c'est bien de cela dont nous avons
besoin en effet dans notre pays face au
défi démographique qui est devant nous
et sortir sans doute d'un dénis
individuel et collectif sur le sujet
parce qu'en 2030 un Français sur 3 aura
plus de 60 ans et c'est donc toute notre
société qui doit aujourd'hui s'y adapter
c'est le sens de la stratégie
interministérielle que nous avons pu
collectivement présenter c'est le sens
de la proposition de loi on a repris nos
débat hier dans un climat qui était je
crois extrêmement précieux en terme de
qualité de travail et c'est le sens
aussi évidemment de l'engagement que
j'ai pris avec la première ministre sur
une loi de programmation sur le grand
âge je crois que c'était quelque chose
d'attendu évidemment par les
parlementaires vous le demandiez et vous
aviez raison de le demander attendu par
les professionnels et cette loi de
programmation elle doit justement
permettre de tracer des trajectoires des
trajectoires de financement évidemment
sur la question du grand âge et des
trajectoire en terme de recrutement des
professionnels aujourd'hui vous l'avez
dit les professionnels ils sont dans une
forme de de perte de sens par rapport à
leur métier c'est pas les voocation qui
manque c'est le fait de la manière avec
laquelle ce métier peut-être exercé ces
métiers peuvent être exercés qui font
qu'on est dans un risque de cercle
vicieux où finalement pénurie de
professionnelle engendre la pénurie de
professionnelle et met à mal à la fois
la qualité de la prise en charge des
patients des bénéficiaires des résidents
mais surtout la qualité du travail des
professionnels c'est pour ça que nous
devons tout faire pour tenir la
trajectoire que nous avons annoncé de
50000 soignants supplémentaires parce
que c'est notre responsabilité pour
garantir que les éepads puissent
fonctionner et qu'au-delà des éepads
700000 personnes qui sont accompagnées
le virage domiciliaire réellement puisse
être pris en compte et tout le parcours
résidentiel c'est pour cela que nous
devons faire cette loi de programmation
c'est pour cela que nous devons
renforcer les moyens c'est pour cela que
nous devons avoir une trajectoire de
financement parce que nous devons en
effet tenir la trajectoire telle qu'elle
a été annoncée par le président de la
République je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
michaelo pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
je m'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
outremes sur l'enclavement des habitants
de waliss Futuna ils sont victimes de
problèmes majeurs de communication tout
simple tout spécialement les habitants
de foutouna l'avion est le seul moyen de
sortir de chez eux nos liaisons sont
aléatoires
irrégulières difficilement programmables
il faut tenir compte des réquisitions
qui à tout moment peuvent intervenir les
déplacements des malades des étudiants
des professionnels des administratifs
sont périeux et ceux de mes collègues
qui viennent jusqu'à chez nous le const
le constatent
imquablement il faut réserver de mois à
l'avance pour espérer avoir une place le
fret aérien est d'une capacité ridicule
tant pour l'intérile que pour
l'extérieur comment les commerçants
peuvent-ils importer comment les
producteurs peuvent-ils exporter
pourquoi ne sommes-nous pas des servis
de vol cargo dans quelques jours le
prestateur de la desserte intérile va
changer un seul a répondu à l'appel
d'offre quand l'état des aéronuf laisse
à désirer l'inquiétude est général quant
à la ré de ce service indispensable aux
habitants que prévoyez-vous pour
garantir aux habitants de futona qu'ils
ne seront plus qui ne seront pas une
nouvelle fois isolé de même de moyens
maritime monsieur le ministre c'est
toute une réflexion nécessaire à mener
sur les moyens de l'État pour
désenclaver W founa nous av nous avons
besoin de services adaptés de même pour
les secours terrestres et maritimes nous
venons de déplorer la disparition de
deux pêcheurs faute de moyens
intervention la surveillance des EAU la
surveillance des eaux nationales a
besoin plus que jamais des outils
adaptés en proximité le gouvernement
est-il prêt à mettre en place une vraie
politique de désenclavement aérienne et
maritime nécessaire à la survie de ce
territoire de mener une étude sur les
moyens à mettre en place comme une
liaison maritime passagère et marchandis
ou encore un hélicoptère à l'image de ce
qui se passe en Polynésie ou aux îles
ferroé et comme des études récentes de
collègues merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue merci la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Vigier ministre délégué en
charge des outres
mèes merci madame la Présidente madames
messieur les députés monsieur le député
michaeles co merci de votre question qui
permet d'abord de rappeler tout ce que
fait le gouvernement pour aider le
transport
aérien pour aider deux compagnies corsèr
et austral plusis de 300 millions
d'euros ont été apportés ces trois
dernières années deuxièmement je permet
de vous dire que concernant la dessert
de Wallis et
Futuna vous savez très bien qu'il a une
délégation de service public laquelle
délégation étit attribué à rcin ça
changera au 1er janvier 2024 c'est r
loyauté qui va avoir cette délégation de
service public la Direction générale de
l'aviation civile la direction des
ultremers sera là pour accompagner la
transition entre les deux délégations
vous nous demandez ce que l'on fait on
finance on finance 50 % 2700000 € pour
cette délégation des services public
donc vous voyez que walis et Futuna
n'est pas oublié ensuite vous parlez du
transport maritime vous le savez puisque
on a eu l'occasion d'échanger sur cette
question et et merci de l'intérêt que
vous portez à ce problème du transport
maritime pour les habitants de wallus de
Futuna à la fois pour les passagers mais
également pour le fret une étude est en
cours qui est financée intégralement par
le ministère 140000 € et les résultats
de cette étude nous les connaîtrons à la
fin du premier trimestre 2024 donc vous
voyez que pour le transport aérien pour
le transport maritime nous sommes
présents et j'en profite pour rappeler
côti de la continuité territoriale le
soutien sera passera de 70 millions à 93
millions d'euros en 2024 bref pour payer
une grande partie des billets d'avion
pour celles et ceux qui rentrent de
l'Hexagone vers les territoires
ultramarins avec une annonce
particulière pour les jeunes pour les
étudiants qui dès les vacances de Noël
qu'ils soi boursiers ou pas boursiers
pourront revenir dans leur pays avec un
billet totalement pris en charge donc
sur toutes ces questions nous sommes
présents et merci de votre implication
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le député je vais donner
la parole à Monsieur Dino signeri pour
les républicains je voudrais lui rendre
hommage parce que c'est probablement sa
dernière question au gouvernement ça
fait plus de 20 ans que vous êtes engagé
au service de cette Assemblée nationale
et au service de nos compatriotes et
donc au nom de l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale je voudrais
vous remercier monsieur le député pour
votre engagement sans faille au service
des Français au sein de cette Assemblée
nationale
merci
merci merci madame la Présidente vos
propos me vont du fond du cœur je
profite mes chers collègues de cette
dernière question après plus de 21 ans
sur ces bancs pour vous remercier ainsi
que chacun de mes collègues pour le
travail accompli ensemble de jours et
parfois de nuits le plus souvent avec
beaucoup de respect malgré nos
divergences je mesure pleinement la
chance qui a été la mienne de siéger au
sein de cette noble assemblée qui
raisonne encore avec des voix de
clémenau de georess de Jacques Chirac et
tant d'autres cette complémentarité des
travaux à Paris et des engagements sur
le terrain permet de toujours chercher
le meilleur pour notre pays et ce ce qui
doit nous animer je tiens à remercier
aussi tous les fonctionnaires les
collaborateurs tous ceux qui travaillent
discrètement dans cette belle maison où
j'ai été honoré de servir mes
concitoyens du département de la
Loire ma question s'adresse à Monsieur à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
j'associe à ma question la future député
madame Sylvie Bonet bien sûr Jean-Pierre
et l'ensemble de mon groupe LR c'est
évidemment avec beaucoup émotion que je
souhaite vous alerter monsieur le
ministre sur l'octroit des trimestres
supplémentaires pour les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires pour le calcul de
leur retraite cette bonification
inscrite à l'article 24 de la loi du 14
avril 2023 est une reconnaissance
importante de l'engagement citoyen des
sapeurs pompiers volontaires au service
de la
collectivité et Monsieur le Ministre
permettrait aussi de susciter des
vocations car je veux le rappeler ils
sont indispensables dans nos territoires
et je tiens à leur rendre un hommage
particulier cet
après-midi un amendement sénatorial
adopté prévoyit trois trimestres après
10 ans d'ancienneté complété d'un
trimestre tous les 5 ans mais il a été
supprimé en commission mixte paritaire
et la bonification a été renvoyée à un
décret du Conseil d'État or à ce jour le
décret n'a toujours pas été publié au
Journal officiel pouvez-vous nous dire
monsieur le ministre nous dire quand ce
décret sera pris et nous confirmer qu'il
fixera une majoration de 3 trimestres
après 10 ans d'ancienneté complété d'un
trimestre tous les 5 ans et je voudrais
avoir une pensé pour mon ami Hubert
welffrin merci beaucoup monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outres
mires merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député de l'innocinerie
permettez-moi également en mon nom
personnel et au nom du du gouvernement
de vous remercier pour le travail que
vous avez apporté au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale et j'ai été témoin pour être
votre collègue et aussi comme ministre
de vos apports même en cas de divergence
toujours extrêmement sérieux et dans une
circonscription qui vous a réélu très
populaire et donc vous êtes je suis j'en
suis toujours certain l'avocat et
évidemment permettez-moi d'adresser à
votre suppléante qui va siéger ici de
nos vœux de bienvenue dans dans quelques
jours peut-être vous dire Monsieur le
Député que je connais votre engagement
pour les sapurs pompiers depuis
longtemps qu'il soit professionnels ou
volontaire et je veux ici vous rassurer
puisqu'il s'agit d'une disposition qui a
été votée dans l'article 24 du projetlo
de financement de la sécurité sociale
qui prévoit en effet des trimestres
supplémentaires dans le cadre que vous
avez évoqué pour les sapurs pompiers et
vous dire qu'évidemment ce décret va
être pris le ministre en charge du
travail en charge des retraites et
moi-même pour que dans les semaines qui
viennent j'espère d'ici le 31 décembre
monsieur le député ce décret puisse
sortir il va accompagner énorm ormément
de dispositions favorables au sa
pompiers que vous
avez continuement porté qui ont été je
crois accepté à la fois dans l'autre
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur dans la loi matraace et dans
les dernières annonces l'exonération des
charges pour les employeurs de SAP
pompiers volontairees c'était une
revendication aussi très ancienne pour
la l'avocation de nos SAP pompiers la
nouvelle prestation de fidélisation et
de reconnaissance qui aujourd'hui n'est
pas très adapté et vous l'avez souvent
porté mais également la consolidation de
notre modèle de volontariat et de
professionnalisme qui cohabit dans nos
territoires singulièrement dans les
territoires soit urbains et ruraux qui
correspondent par exemple au département
de la Loire que vous avez représenté si
longtemps à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
donc plein je crois de devoir accomplis
que vous devez désormais pé quitter
laassemblée nationale en vous remerciant
une nouvelle fois pour votre soutien
très fort à l'action des SAP pompiers et
de manière générale je le sais aux
agents du ministère de l'Intérieur je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre donc
cette séance de question au gouvernement
est terminée la séance est suspendue et
se poursuivra par une déclaration du
gouvernement relative au partenariat
renouvelés entre la France et les pays
africains suivi d'un
débat